my god are we best friend hi I'm
Jonathan Vanessa and I'm here at
BuzzFeed I'm going to be doing a
gorgeous fan Q&A whilst playing with
kittens this is my baby liza minnelli
this is bug ii and this is Harry Larry I
love kitten so much
bring on the cans or as I would say at
home bring on the bins there's a cute
little item but not really you know it's
like up never you'll buy it oh my god
do they need home I'm planning a trip
somewhere remote soon how can I make my
hair look good without access to a hair
dryer clean and just get you a hair tie
like that's what you're going remote for
it my right like put it up who cares
like just make sure you got some dry
shampoo and maybe some like a hair pin
so you can do like a cute little messy
knot instead of like a basic knot oh my
gosh mean Wilco we're talking about
adopting an orange one do you believe in
aliens that meme is very funny I do
think this are we literally the only
people like around like seriously like
it seems like such a big world and that
was so rude do not talk to your sisters
like that that is not how we get adopted
how do you keep such a smile on your
face with everything happening in the
world it's very simple I get this
question a lot I go on Twitter and I
just spit out every piece of like dip
triolic rage I have I take out all my
anger on the news on everyone and
everything I go to Twitter so that's one
thing go on Twitter tell me how you
really feel no one really excited anyway
so it's fine then the other thing I do
is I really go on my Instagram Explorer
page I think having a strong connection
with your Explorer page to have it
populated with things that make you
happy you know whether that's figure
skating gymnastics you know figure
skating from the 80s or collegiate so
for me Mike or he just figure skating
gymnastics DIY hair stuff in short lifts
gay if that really is my recipe for
success oh my god are you a calico
perfect kitten did you just discover me
do you want to come home with me food
what's one piece of advice you have on
how to stay looking fly while on an
airplane hydration hydration hydration
honey you need like a travel-size serum
and moisturizer and sunscreen so that
you stay hydrated because
we get really dehydrated planes and also
I think it's like a drink a lot of water
and also I read that like you should
never have the ice on planes because
it's like nasty in Germany but I don't
know if that's true but maybe just bring
your bottled water or something oh my
gosh I'm obsessed with you what is the
most important thing I've learned it's a
few folds one sometimes people can tote
surprise you and you can teach someone
who has had long-standing questionable
habits cuter habits and actually have
those habits stick which is great like
I've learned that people are capable of
changing and I've also learned that like
I will never understand Trump people but
that we can agree on helping you learn
to floss because who loses when you
learn how to floss nobody oh my gosh are
we so obsessed with playing it wasn't
what suprising person that watches for
I'm constantly surprised
I think someone told me that Michelle
Obama was dad but I think I might be
hallucinating not so I don't know oh my
gosh were you a little calico yeah I
said I'm really interesting about calico
cats they're like very rarely boys
there's something because my grandma
tried to explain it to me once I asked
them any questions you kept telling me
to shut up so I can't remember
okay so self-care and even simple
hygiene can be so difficult when you're
depressed and have no energy do you have
any tips for taking care of yourself
when you're completely drained great
question I would have two tips for this
one is is that I think that you know the
morning time is so important to kind of
like get the trajectory of your day on
like a more gorgeous like upswing so if
you can get to some of your self-care
and hygienic moments in the morning to
kind of give yourself the best chance of
getting yourself feeling more gorgeous
than the day but like an internal
gorgeousness not like an external one
then the other thing I would say is that
like break it down and make it smaller
just start with like brushing your teeth
in like a floss just like get up and
blossom brush just do that like don't
even worry about anything just basic
gorgeous getting your teeth clean and
then go take a walk Queen and give
yourself a hug cuz it's okay it's
alright we all get to press team are you
an adoptable little kitten do you want
three brothers five plus three is eight
eight it's not too much oh my gosh I'll
be like Brad Pitt and Angelina Jolie but
with cats before the world fell apart
you really mean how do you make yourself
a priority without being too selfish and
be
guilty when you find out let me know I
don't know like get a cat like I think
here's like give yourself permission to
like take what you need and if you
really have a very connected piece of
yourself that feels like you're like out
of balance in a selfish way be open to
hearing that but I think there's a
difference between like taking care of
yourself and like being selfish you're
also your own best teacher so like even
opening yourself up to that question I
think you'll find the answer that you
need I found the new cat that I need so
I think you'll find the answer to what
you need her we passed friend Carol
we passed a friend we the pets and
what's your name gonna be what I'll name
do you want where you Lou it are you
Louie
what celebrity encounter made you the
most starstruck here let me tell you a
story honey when I met Laurie Hernandez
a member of the final five gold medal
winning US gymnastics team from Rio when
I met her backstage of this thing that
we were about that it's like a ghost
smack me across the face as far as they
could and I did three sinead turns into
a wall and just started sobbing
uncontrollably and her mom had to like
coax me out from behind a corner cuz I
was freaking out so hard and then she
was like what is the matter with you and
I was like I don't even know like I just
love you so much and also like that
the unclenching of my heart what I saw
her do her front aerial on beam last
week on Instagram just knowing that
she's training for that comeback I'm
feeling so much release and like silver
lining because like even though so much
is going to hell in a handbasket at
least Laurie Hernandez it's training
again you got a good show who's boss it
telling have you always wanted to have a
career as a comic great question
I thought that to do stand-up I thought
that you needed to like pay your dues
and do a hundred thousand Mike nights
and I really looked up to see a no
comedians like Margaret Cho was one of
my idols and I loved getting to work
with her and see her perform so much to
end up and it just is something I didn't
think I'd have the opportunity to do you
know the stand-up comedy is really hard
to break into there's not that and full
of space to get your foot in the door
and so to have someone come to the table
and want to help me and this way has
been really amazing did I always know
that I wanted to be a fan of comic not
necessarily but I'm really happy that I
was given this opportunity and I took it
and and made the leap and it has been
one of the most rewarding and like
passionate things that I've gotten to do
as an adult so it's really party hotels
that Comedy presents ten nights at
Jonathan van Ness comes out on November
12 on hotels.com YouTube page so headed
up we can't wait to share this gorgeous
little moment with you honey you laugh
you cry you cry some more you cry
hardest and then you laugh a little bit
just kidding it's more funny than as sad
thanks for having me BuzzFeed and all
these gorgeous kittens are adoptable at
the North Shore Animal League America
super you already got a home didn't you
[Music]